[Music] Please welcome from BP executive vice
president technology Acha Amebleu and senior vice
president digital delivery Sanjay Pande. [Music]
So um hello everyone. This is Thunderhorse. This
is one of our platforms that we operate in the
we're here from BP. This is one of our platforms,
our biggest platform that we operate in the
Gulf of America. Um really hi everyone. It's
really great to be with you today. Um we've been
one we're one of Palunteer's first commercial
customers. We've been working with Palunteer for
over 10 years and it's really been a phenomenal
journey to be working with them. This has been
Palanteer has been a huge value creator for our
company. It's been value for employees, value for
our shareholders, for our customers across the
board. We've gotten huge value from what we've
done with Palunteer. Quick introduction by the
way, my name is Amecha Ameble. I'm the EVP for
technology at BP and I'm here with my colleague
Sanjay Pande who's our senior vice president for
digital delivery. So for those of you who may be
unfamiliar with BP, we've been operating for about
116 years. So a long time as a company. Um at
the heart of our company, what our strategy is is
we're about growing. We our strategy is to deliver
um energy to the world today and tomorrow. We grow
our we're growing our oil and gas business. We're
focusing our customer and products business and
we're investing into the energy transition in a
very disciplined way. And technology underpins
everything that we do in this in this part of
our business. Um technology underpins us improving
our operating efficiency, driving competitiveness,
and as you can imagine, keeping people
safe and secure in all of the platforms
and everywhere we operate. And our approach to
technology is based in all of this. And at core,
at the core of our approach to technology, we use
Palunteer. We've worked with Palunteer, as I said,
for over a decade. Um, we have we've been doubling
we're we've been worked with we've worked with
Palunteer for over a decade, and now we're
doubling down with that decade's worth of work
with the new AIP system out of Palunteer. And this
what this is going to be doing is really helping
us drive a lot of competitiveness for BP as a
company. Um what we're trying to do really as a
company is build we're we're building an ontology.
We we are actually advancing the ontology we build
as with Palanteer as a company looking at every
part of our company and connecting everything that
we do. We we're trying to build a fully integrated
fully forecastable business across our entire
company. What you can see on the screen here is
this is our Sherlock suite for example. What this
does is it helps us look at how we manage when
we have failures in our wells or our production
systems. Everything goes into the ontology.
Everything is trackable. It's connected through
Palunteer and accessible to engineers everywhere
in our company. So, this is what we're trying to
do to make sure everything we do from our wells
all the way through our platforms, everything
it's all connected. And what does this look like?
Another thing we're doing, we're building so um we
actually heard Dr. Karp talk about data earlier
today. We've heard other people talk about data.
We're making this data accessible to everybody in
our company. Again, using the using Palunteer's
Foundry and the ontology, it's pulling the whole
data from across our company all the way together.
We're um using operational data from our fields
in the Gulf of America all the way through to
our wells in Kazan in the deserts of Kazan and
making sure we're understanding actually what
we can learn for how failures occur, how we make
our systems better, how we make our systems more
resilient, how we make our systems more productive
every day. This is what we're doing through our
Palunteer system. And you can imagine in a world
where previously we actually had engineers trying
to pull all of these data insights together just
not connected not learning from each other. We are
in our upstream business now. We've moved past
that and that's what the ontology has helped us
put in place. But we didn't we haven't actually
we're not stopping there. We're taking this to
our retail sites. We're taking it to our trading
systems. We're taking it to our we're taking this
across everywhere we operate in the company
starting in the upstream to our refineries to
make sure and our traders. We have a big trading
organization to make sure they can leverage data
across our entire company to drive value for
BP. So this innovation really is I would say
you know I'm sure many of you worry or you have
conversations about returns on investment of
different technologies you invest in. for us.
I can say to you again very confidently year
on year, we're getting triple figure investments
from the investments that we've made in Palunteer
without without failing. People across our
company are we know about this and yeah,
this is very clear. It's this is a value this is
a been a big force value multiplier for us as a
company. Um Sanjay is actually going to talk you
through some details of what this has looked like
in the Thunderhorse asset that we talked about.
Again, we start there from a molecular basis and
you can see how this can be or how it can be and
is applied to the rest of our company. Sanjay,
thank you Mecca. Um, excited to be here uh and
represent the work of our teams and our business
people uh across BP. Um, this is Thunderhorse.
It's our largest production and drilling platform
in the Gulf of America, capable of 250,000 barrels
of oil a day. For a sense of scale, the main deck
on Thunderhorse is about the size of uh three
regulation sized football fields. It's massive. Um
operating a platform like this is highly complex
and we have to balance maximizing efficiency with
the safety of our teams. It's a tough problem.
The kind of complexity here translates to
working with over 60,000 pieces of equipment
uh attached to 40,000 real-time sensors and
um 40 4,000 synthetic uh sensors streaming data
from the asset. We ran over 1.4 million digital
twin simulations in the last year alone. This
kind of visibility that we get through Foundry
is transformational at the asset level. Um, our
teams, our engineers, I can interface with every
dimension of the asset in one place in a way that
I couldn't do before. And with AIP, we're not only
looking at structured data, we're integrating
and leveraging them into the same ontology.
This is one asset, Thunderhorse. We're scaling
this capability across dozens more globally. The
foundation though is only as valuable as
our ability to drive effective operations
and decisions. And so by integrating the live
sensor data with our physics-based models along
with best practices and the engineering
expertise of our talented operators,
we're optimizing our assets without compromising
safety. is job one for us is safety and capturing
production deviations below target to support
the reliability of the equipment and preventive
maintenance across an equipment class and at
the asset level. Um in the last 12 months the
strong foundation has accelerated our ability
to develop new use cases and drive value from
AI. Um we'll look at two that we've built on
AIP. Uh starting in the optimization space,
um routing is one of our newest expansions and
performing routing optimization through brute
force techniques would take multiple weeks to set
up, execute and evaluate and the existing digital
twin system optimiz optimizers only give us a
singular optimal solution. With AI, our engineers
now can set up and run these optimizations in
hours. It's a massive deal. uh an engineer can
see the optimal solution and options close to
optimal allowing us to consider operational
factors like schedules risks and recommending
a configuration to increase the production.
Second one we'll look up we we'll look at how
we're removing data silos and we talked about data
sharing across organization and acha talked about
that a little bit. It's vital to us as a large
multinational and having an integrated data set
our teams can use. Um, so we'll look at how we're
analyzing uh our equipment data at scale. With
AIP, we're further enhancing the data foundation
by digitally encoding our best practices and
engineering expertise using the AI agents
um through AIP to surface insights in seconds.
This has been scaled um relatively simply in
fact across a 1.4 million pieces of equipment
uh across our global oil and gas assets and
this has reduced the time to get to operational
insights on maintenance data by 75%. To put a
finer point on it, this is all about operational
excellence for us. Safety's at the core and assets
like Thunderhorse that you saw um are incredibly
incredibly hard uh to maintain and execute. Um so
we're not just talking about unlocking value
though, we're measuring it. And now we're in
we're expanding the insights gained from our
oil and gas business as a Mecha talked about
to other parts of our portfolio. It's deeply
complex an integrated energy value chain and
this is how technology is enabling BP strategy uh
in partnership with uh with Palunteer. Thank you.
[Music]